[Musique]
pourquoi est-ce que je devrais en garder
c'est à guichet fermé que se jouer cet
après midi là la sorcière du placard aux
balais met en scène par deux comédiens
de la compagnie parisienne tête en l'air
le spectacle est inspiré des contes de
la rue broca de pia et par
la sorcière du placard aux balais c'est
vraiment on va dire un classique de
contes pour enfants donc c'est vrai que
parfois on voit que il ya des enfants
qui connaissent déjà l'histoire qui ont
pu la découvrir avec leurs parents on
semble que les parents ont à coeur de se
remémorer des souvenirs d'enfance donc
c'est vraiment on va dire un spectacle
qui fédère l'histoire est simple une
sorcière habite dans une maison et
cherche à déloger le nouveau
propriétaire en lui faisant peur et en
faisant des parts et avec lui les
comédiens je sais ce spectacle depuis
cinq ans on a fait une mise en scène par
exemple qui reprend un des objets qu'on
peut trouver dans les chambres d'enfants
on a fait aussi appel à des masques pour
mêler un peu l'art du théâtre l'art par
exemple de la commedia dell arte pendant
50 minutes les spectateurs souvent âgés
entre 3 et 10 ans ont participé au
spectacle
oui on a aimé
mais moi j'adorais quand le monsieur il
faisait semblant tout mais moi je les
bien aimés colas ans hier à l arrivée
parce que ça faisait un peu peur oui
j'ai bien tout aimé me moment
où j où j'ai que j'aimais le plus
c'était avec la la première fois que la
petite souris j'ai vu était trop
mignonne la sorcière du placard aux
balais sera joué mercredi 27 jeudi 28 et
vendredi 29 octobre à 14 heures 30 et
dimanche 31 octobre à 15 heures
[Musique]